the graph of f is shown below
let g of x be equal to the definite
integral from zero to x of f of t
dt now at first when you see this you're
like wow this is this is strange i have
a function that is being defined by an
integral a definite integral but one of
its bounds are x and you should just say
well well this is okay a function can be
defined any which way and as we'll see
it's actually quite straightforward to
evaluate this
so g of negative two g of
negative 2 and i'll do the negative 2 in
a different color g of negative 2. well
what we do is we take this expression
right over here this definite integral
and everywhere we see an x we replace it
with a negative 2. so this is going to
be equal to
the integral from 0 to x
of and i'll write x in a second f of t
dt
well x is now negative 2. this is now
negative 2. and so how do we figure out
what this is now before we even look at
this graph you might say okay this is
the the region under the area of the
region under the graph y equals f of t
between negative two and zero but you
have to be careful
notice our upper bound here is actually
a lower number than our lower bound
right over here so it will be nice to
swap those bounds so we can truly view
it as the area of the region under f of
t above the t axis between those two
bounds
and so when you swap the bounds this is
going to be equal to
negative
definite integral from negative 2
negative 2 to
0
of f of t
dt
and now
what we have right over here what i'm
squaring off in magenta this is the area
under the curve f between negative 2 and
0. so between
negative 2
and 0. so that is this area
right over here
that we care about
now what is that going to be
well you could there's a bunch of
different ways that you could do this
you could split it off into a square and
a triangle the area of this square right
over here is four it's two
by two and just make sure to make sure
you look at the units sometimes each
square doesn't represent one square unit
so but in this case it does so that's
four and then up here this is half of
four right if it was all of this that
would be four this triangle is half of
four so this is two right over there or
you could view this as base times height
times one half which is going to be two
times two times 1 half and so this area
right over here is 6. so this part is 6
but we can't forget that negative sign
so this is going to be equal to negative
negative
6.
and so
g of negative 2 is
negative 6.